[Music]
oh B
no oh my
God oh my I want you to look at his face
no no no no no I'm not no I'm not doing
that look at that face I'm not doing
that I want to ask you guys on this face
where do you guys detect any hint of
Shame cheesec Factory y'all I a get out
this
pH
yes uh would you want me to open the
door for
you look at look are you you're
recording me
yeah yeah this is the Cheesecake
Factory this is the Cheesecake Factory
y'all what's the problem with that this
is a chain restaurant who takes someone
that looks like this she's filming it
let me film it guys
who I mean who like what you're not able
to have a conversation with the the
[__] right there you want to
broadcast that [__] you the mother the
guy you should have the conversation
with is right like right there you just
have to turn and talk to him no no you
decided to whip out your phone and
broadcast the thing that looks like this
to a chain restaurant you want to talk
about it I'm I'm fine with talking about
it even in front of them oh yeah I want
to talk about it some of you seem so
miserable to be around that there's a
part of me that prays you die
alone oh I thought not because I wish
something bad on you I just don't wish
something bad on other people who have
to deal with you so when you say that
someone die alone it's not really like I
want you to die alone I just don't want
you to [__] every someone else's life no
it's like your Co I just need you to
quarantine yeah you need to be by
yourself and think about yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah we're all immunized yeah
yeah yeah yeah you a disease mhm so stay
home come on get on in the car yeah we
going to talk about
it oh
okay okay so so yes let's talk about it
let's talk about it so you expect a man
to go all out on the first day is that
right I mean you're supposed to look I
mean when you take out a beautiful
woman she's
beautiful and he's
courting you're being generous but okay
a beautiful
woman and you're courting her because I
I get courted so you're courting her
right you're supposed to take care of
her you're supposed to cover her you're
supposed to protect her cherish her
treat her well right yeah she supposed
to do I agree I I went into the state as
I
expect uh with the expectations from
myself to keep you safe you know to
respect youh uh to pay for your food of
course pick you up of course and just
treat you like a gentleman which I
believe I have done I mean you you've
been pretty nice but I mean cheesecake
P I on the other hand have certain
expectations for a girl I go out with on
the first date I expect her to be
respectful too I expect her to be
cooperative and and at least you know
uh what did I do that wasn't Cooperative
not get out the [__] car when you're
supposed to go eat when you at that at
your destination pulling out your cell
phone so you could broadcast this to
everyone else and try to make him look
Goofy
I don't know is that teamwork to you
like let me ask you a question do you
think it's a good sense of teamwork when
someone on your team does something bad
and you broadcasted to the whole public
customers everyone alike family members
is that teamwork to you as a matter of
fact as a matter of fact I was working
in a company and my manager yelled at my
sister remember that cuz my my sister
and I were working in the same spot
selling cell phones and this [__] deci
I don't know she was having a bad day
and she decided to yell at myself sister
in front of customers and not only the
fact that she was my my sister but also
don't yell at me in front of
customers if you're manager of anything
deal with your [__] not in front of
customers that's teamwork that you want
to imply in in a work environment and
when you're trying to date someone
that's a bit the same thing you're
trying to have a teamwork you're try to
work together true life that's going to
be pretty much all your life your life
is going to be try to teamwork through
all the life right don't brought the
thing so if you're auditioning me cuz
that's what it is you know you don't do
this you don't do that you want to
broadcast yeah no that's not team it's
absolutely not teamwork no places of
work would consider that teamwork no
team would consider that teamwork any
team that you play I wouldn't go into
the news yeah but that guy does this and
pract no that's not team likee you deal
with your [__] with a conversation with
a person so yeah no you're being a
jackass right now my girl I'm fresh I'm
fit I'm moisturized and
monetized I've said it before I'm going
to say it again it's important to take
care of your skin because you know
that's the first thing that people see
they see your skin and they judge you on
that they don't want to say it but they
actually really do so we're going to go
through that skincare routine together
right with the Bron full products of th
and Le so first thing I do I tie my hair
yep I tie my hair because I don't want
to get my hair in the way twice a week
what I do is I take the exfoliating
scrub cuz I want to get in the nooks and
crannies all right I go up there we
always forget the edges if it goes a
little bit in my hair it's okay it's not
a PR close your eyes M your face you're
going to use a
clot you have the da face wash
[Music]
boom you're going to put the under eye
cream before you moisturize that's what
I do you take the eye cream take one
little dab under your eyes like that
takes away the bags okay when I'm done
with that I take my morning facial
everybody likes a little facial in the
morning pause and just apply it like so
so your face is
moisturized click on the link below get
your 30% off and a free gift yep and get
your skin care routine
on
um what did I do that wasn't Cooperative
well I mean like even like uh when we
were walking to the car uh you wouldn't
uh put your hand around my arm or
anything like that or pull my hand or
anything like that I mean it's too early
for that okay I know I can respect that
I can respect that when uh I got to your
apartment to pick you up uh you didn't
want to invite me in I can respect that
too we're not we're not there yes okay I
know you and then
but I mean I feel like I'm doing
everything I'm supposed to do as a woman
take this one I'm not saying
anything bro if a girl ever talk to me
like that yo get the [__] up out of my
car yo get the [__] up out of my car IID
take her phone Chuck it out the window I
said go pick up your [__] why why is she
acting like she got taken to [__]
McDonald's and is she not cool with it
that's fine you're allowed to just leave
pulling out your cell phone so you can
film the whole thing you got these mid
ass women with the biggest inflated
heads because somebody on Twitter or Tik
Tok told them they're queens or whatever
it's like yo chill the out I'm not
saying you guys can't feel yourselves
but some of you guys' heads is so big
you could be hot air balloons chill out
I'm just saying some of y'all watching
at home
going relax it ain't cute nobody think
that shit's sexy
but I mean I feel like I'm doing
everything I'm supposed to do as a
woman I got myself all made up there
nothing wrong with The Cheesecake
Factory right yes there's a lot wrong
with The Cheesecake Factory look well
look at I mean look at my plan where we
were going to go originally see now
that's that's where that's where we
should have went Ari right there call
him call them no what do you mean no see
I speciically told you both yesterday
and this morning that I'd come to pick
you up at 4:00 a.m. at 400 p.m. right
and I got to your place at 400 p.m. you
didn't even come downstairs for another
hour and so I was waiting downstairs
oh B
no oh my my
God oh my
God oh my go why are you still talking
with that girl yes why are you still
talking with that girl you should have
she shouldn't even have access to your
car you're waited and now you waited an
hour for a steaming pile of garbage and
then she you waited for the
trash I didn't know you got the job as
being the garbage man cuz you waited an
out the garbage man don't even wait for
a trash the garage man just roll through
pick them [__] up and toss them in you
waited an hour for
trash that's on you that's on all the
men who don't have enough self-respect
to leave somebody listen if somebody
going to be late they don't even text
you the courtesy let you know before you
even get there so you could be at home
and wait there instead of showing up
that early they don't give a [__] about
you and if you showing up there there
and you waiting an hour she don't give a
[__] about you and after she's made you
wait for an hour if she show up on a
date and she act yo you [__] you better
be fine with some
McDonald's get you a Happy Meal yay
somebody better get a Happy Meal cuz I
ain't happy having to wait 1 hour for
you uh-uh you better accept anything I
know me okay if I'm that late that I
[__] up somewh schedule like that okay
you best believe I'm going to be on my
best behavior but this woman is so
raised by animals that not only is she
late but [__] want to catch an attitude
like she was the one waiting an
hour no no no she's trash and you picked
up some trash pulled that [__] out come
to find out there's doooo inside that's
on you my friend leave the trash on the
curb that's on you that's all I'm going
say go ahead preach go ahead where go
ahead where where you want to go go
ahead where we have an hour to wa from
trash go ahead where where hell's the
[__] do you want me to
go my friend you happy now my
friend I want you look at his face no no
no no no I'm not no I'm not doing that
look at that face I'm not doing that I
want to ask you guys on this face where
do you guys detect any hint of Shame
and shame anywhere an hour on a date and
you act like that the thing
is [__] could happen and now we at your
place has a bit [__] up but [__] could
happen but when this [__] happens and
you pull out this
attitude D I don't even know an hour
that means that there was no explanation
no nothing no sorry no nothing all right
the entitlement was real she shouldn't
have access to your
car I'm not going to give it a second
chance or nothing like that it's
off it's very off you didn't even come
downstairs for another hour and so I was
waiting downstairs I understand for an
hour but I wasn't expecting for work to
take me so long I got home a little late
and like I said I don't know know you
well enough to invite you up into my
apartment that is not possible and
that's why I'm saying I'm thinking okay
if we're not there in a relationship to
you know meet at your apartment then
maybe we're not ready in a relationship
for such a nice fancy Rel uh restaurant
as Arya especially if I'm paying for the
whole thing which I'm still willing to
do I would have been okay but
if we're late I mean I told you twice
late it wasn't that late we literally
left your place at the time the
reservation was supposed to be oh and I
specifically said for it because maybe
we could get there early the reason why
we're at Cheesecake Factory is because
you're an hour late and our reservation
got busted so the reason why we're not
at the way they I'm sleep the the the
the reason why
we're not where we're supposed to be or
where you wanted to be or where I
schedule is because of you and you're
still doing all this
[__] um there's a wonderful song that I
call white people Kryptonite and it's
called Uh creep and not the black person
uh creep not the Black Version creep uh
the white version of creep about radio
right uh yeah radio head and at the end
there's a wonderful part in the song
that every White people love and
everybody should love cuz it's a
wonderful song and it goes run run
run maybe we could get there early and
even have some time to get to know each
other on the way there and while we're
in the parking lot I mean me for a
reservation we can still get to know
each other isn't there another
restaurant you can call that like you
know the equivalent to that I mean I I
you don't understand look at me I cannot
go in the Cheesecake Factory oh
uh I'm going to speed this up see if
there's anything interesting there's
nothing I will die that's embarrassing
listen I as I said I have very specific
certain expectations doubt I can tell
it's not going to be there I and maybe
we're not right for each other so
respectfully I'm going to just drop you
off oh no you didn't yeah so you just
want to call it a night I mean isn't
there some kind of compromise or
something ladies can you believe this
I'm sorry y'all this this a sketch that
has to be a sketch it's not
real I I if I don't feel respected I am
not going to go through the rest of day
well I mean you are serious you're
really leaving yeah I mean you didn't
want this place anyway right I
mean I mean I understand that I was late
I understand that I understand that I
could have been a bit more Cooperative
you had you made some good points that's
why I'm willing to compromise are you
sure you want to go home uh I don't have
a lot of rules I don't have a lot of
expectations for our first dat but I've
already said them and you broken
everyone so I'm sorry we're dropping you
off
home all right whatever well the only
reason I don't think it's a sketch is
cuz that dude does not look like he's
acting at
all it cannot be real it can't be I mean
if it is real it cannot it cannot be
real it cannot if it if if it's a sketch
he's an amazing actor yes like like
amazing amazing pristine her I don't
know she look she she looked fake
anyways her fak everything she
broadcasting right but him that was
unbelievable acting chistine so Hey
listen if you got me Kudos but I don't
think that was acting that's acting so
good for you for having some
self-respect and going to drop her off
that's acting good for that's acting
good for you that's acting yeah yeah she
don't want to take you when you want to
take her out to [__] cheesecake you
don't deserve the nice restaurant good
for y'all don't go thinking that this is
the norm that's not the nor that's not
that's not what I believe the norm is
out there of people or your dating pool
is
try that that's hey I think this [__]
real oh my God I think this is real I
don't know I could be
wrong but nothing like this says she
does a bunch of sketch comedy she's live
right
now and it's just her staring at a
camera
but you know what that means right she's
available no that shit's real that
shit's real yeah uh cuz you took that
voice of the nerdy dude so I thought he
was like you know what that means right
H
lady I would never give her that voice
uh never never is that the norm that's
not the norm it's not the norm that's
just one flated [__] that's that's for
me anything else you want to say no I
don't
yeah